en la víspera de la procesión religiosa
que más fieles Católicos congrega en
Centroamérica Carlos Martínez apenas
tendrá una hora para dormir Guatemala es
el corazón de la fe de la religiosidad
Popular
siendo un feligrés salvadoreño Carlos
viajó hasta antigua Guatemala para
personificar a uno de los romanos de la
centuria
y estamos listos
sumisión es la de marchar por más de 20
horas ininterrumpidas encarnando al
centurión que en la Biblia le pide a
Jesús curar a uno de sus criados es lo
que él vino a hacer es la enseñanza que
Jesús que Jesús se hizo hombre verdad
habitó entre nosotros nos enseñó a
perdonar
cerca de 300.000 personas entre fieles y
curiosos acuden a admirar la escultura
consagrada de Jesús Nazareno de la caída
Pedro Pablo rives feligreses de la
hermandad Santa Lucía asiste a estas
procesiones desde hace 12 años por
devoción recordemos que somos la semana
santa la Jerusalén de Centroamérica y de
América tenemos imágenes que nos
representan de más de 300 años imágenes
que están consagradas acá en la
Guatemala en antigua ciudad patrimonio
cultural de la humanidad durante la
semana santa la ocupación hotelera es de
más del 90%, tras enterarse de las
procesiones a través de un documental
Jessica y su esposo viajaron desde Malta
para vivir de cerca la experiencia
[Música]
es muy bonito hay muchas procesiones
muchas estatuas 60 personas cargando
este Jesús lo estamos disfrutando mucho
el instituto de turismo de Guatemala
Calcula que los ingresos turísticos por
la semana santa podrían sobrepasar los
345 millones de dólares un crecimiento
del 20% con respecto a la semana santa
de 2022 y una recuperación del 95% con
relación a la del 2019
[Música]